[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en 2023 en France on utilise encore de
l'eau potable pour nettoyer sa moto ou
sa voiture
nous au préalable prélevée dans les
nappes phréatiques traitées
et stockées dans les châteaux d'eau
dans certaines communes comme un Grey au
nord d'Orléans on a même dû rajouter une
installation supplémentaire au pied du
réservoir ça ressemble à une maison
c'est en fait une usine de dépollution
notamment pour la sécurisation donc vous
avez l'eau brut qui vient du forage et
qui va passer dans le filtre à charbon
le filtre à charbon les charbons et vont
permettre de retenir l'ensemble des
pesticides qui sont contenus dans l'eau
va continuer son trajet ici et de
manière ensuite à s'acheminer cette
fois-ci vers les résines les résines
elles qui vont permettre de capter
l'ensemble des nitrates dans ces cuves
là concrètement vous avez du charbon qui
permet vraiment de capter de retenir
l'ensemble des pesticides qui sont
contenus dans l'eau un petit peu comme
votre filtre à café le matin le nettoyer
quinze jours avec de le de l'air de ma 2
millions 200000 euros ça fait cher pour
un filtre à café
le prix du mètre cube est ici le plus
élevé de la métropole d'Orléans mais
ingrine n'avait pas le choix pour que
son nom reste potable nous avons confié
à un prestataire qui était la Lyonnaise
des Eaux à l'époque qui s'occupait de la
partie production le soin de porter
cette investissement et donc dans le
prix de l'eau à un grès qui est un euro
70 en fait il y a 1 euro qui correspond
au prix de l'eau et 70 centimes qui
permet de rembourser la société qui a
porté les investissements c'est pour ça
que l'eau est cher
la conformité sur l'ensemble est
traitement nitrates des pesticides qui
est d'abord l'essentiel pour la santé
l'été on est à 60 65 mg
l'été et par contre l'hiver on descend
toujours et on est dans les 53 mg là
actuellement
situé en périphérie de la métropole
entourée de terre cultivées un gré
récupère des polos agricoles rejetés en
amont dans la nappe de Beauce il y a
quelques années la mairie a tenter de
protéger ses points de captage en
prenant un arrêté antipesticides au
final retoquée par la préfecture
l'État interdisé aux communes
la possibilité d'utiliser des produits
phytosanitaires sur l'espace public mais
autorisé l'agriculture et les utiliser
et donc la question que j'ai posée c'est
quelle est la dangerosité des produits
vient-elle du produit ou de celui qui
l'utilise pourquoi moi en tant que mère
je ne peux pas demander aux employés
municipaux dépendent des produits
phytosanitaires pour tuer l'herbe folle
devant un pavillon et pourquoi
l'agriculteur peut les utiliser pour
tuer l'herbe folle derrière le pavillon
c'est quoi c'est une question
d'orientation non personne n'a jamais
répondu là-dessus il y a quand même un
réel problème
[Musique]
l'eau d'Ingré buvez-la c'est sans danger
pas besoin d'inscrire la liste des
ingrédients sur les carafes pour savoir
ce qu'il y a vraiment dans l'eau du
robinet il faut être motivé comme ces
militants associatifs qui étudient
régulièrement les données fournies par
l'agence régionale de santé
[Musique]
c'est peu compréhensible quoi parce que
on a
50 paramètres il faut d'abord s'y
retrouver donc en règle générale on
regarde les nitrates qui sont supérieur
à 30 mg pour une norme à 50 on a
tendance à dire que les gens dans le
Loiret sont biberonné au nitrates et aux
pesticides aujourd'hui un vrai problème
de pollution au niveau du de la
métropole sur la commune d'orme on parle
beaucoup de la commune d'entre parce que
la commune d'orme l'eau est polluée même
si on fait ce qu'il faut au niveau de on
arrête les pesticides on arrête les
nitrates sur la plaine de Beauce on aura
le résultat que dans une trentaine
d'années aujourd'hui on trouve la
trazine faut savoir quand même que la
trazine elle est interdite depuis 2003
aujourd'hui on la trouve dans les nappes
on la trouve dans les analyses donc ça
perdure quoi
la traze et le pesticide le plus présent
dans les relevés d'analyses d'ormes mais
on y trouve aussi une interminable liste
de polluants propagine fénuron tias le
rond pentacloé
certes en petite quantité qui donne tout
de même quelques arrière pensées au
moment de faire ce geste simple
pour limiter les risques cette séquence
a été tournée à Ingré
les gens que je connais boivent de leur
bouteille
c'est mon cas aussi pourquoi mais parce
que boire de la trazine tous les jours
et du nitrate tous les jours je pense
que c'est très mauvais pour la santé
c'est pas moi qui le dit
et globalement je préfère boire de l'eau
qui est censé être meilleur plus potable
selon les données fournies pour 2021 20%
des Français ont reçu une non conforme
en centre Val de Loire plus de 300 000
habitants sont concernés par le problème
principalement dans les zones de
production agricole
et encore des villes comme Ingré qui
dépolluent son eau ne figure pas sur
cette carte ni orme qui se situe juste
en dessous des seuils limites
mais on pourrait voir apparaître
beaucoup plus de petites taches roses si
on faisait des analyses plus fines
l'Europe actuellement est en train de
réfléchir pour justement pour pour
chercher des produits qui n'étaient pas
chercher jusqu'à maintenant mais ça veut
dire que quand on va aller chercher il
va falloir les éliminer après qui va
payer est-ce que c'est le bide chimie
est-ce que c'est pas les entreprises de
la chimie est-ce que c'est les
agriculteurs enfin l'agro-industrie ou
est-ce que c'est les usagers
c'est-à-dire que si on veut être
cohérent normalement on devrait
appliquer les systèmes pollueur payeurs
et actuellement ce qui est appliqué
c'est le système pollué payeur
la pollution des sols due à notre modèle
de développement est une source de
profit permanent pour les grands groupes
qui vendent aux communes leur
savoir-faire technique
Veolia Suez la SAUR se partage le marché
de l'eau mais lorsque la source est de
meilleure qualité elles ne sont plus
indispensables
Saint-Jean-de-Braye fait partie des
villes qui ont arrêté le contrat avec
leurs délégataires privés pour créer une
régie publique de distribution plus
avantageuse pour les finances locales
une activité de plus de 100.000
habitants au départ quand on a été élu
et quand on a commencé à avoir les
comptes rendus de la sort en conseil
municipal on pensait que on avait un bon
délégataire voilà que voilà il y avait
pas ah oui on avait abandonné un
pourcentage de fuite qui était très
faible voilà bon si voilà c'est très
bien bon l'eau était pas très cher par
rapport à d'autres villes de l'agglo bon
donc on se dit bon on a pas un mauvais
délicateur
après
la sort s'est aperçu qu'elle faisait
quand même pas mal de de bénéfices aussi
parce que elle faisait pas tout le
boulot qu'on lui demandait leur lieu des
compteurs était fait par était
sous-traitée par la SAUR à une autre à
une entreprise qui faisait pas le boulot
et donc on s'est rendu compte qu'il y
avait un nombre vraiment très important
de la pression qui payait pas l'eau
depuis longtemps voilà autre problème la
sœur devait à la fin de la délégation
avoir changé tous les branchements plomb
parce qu'a pas été fait non plus il en
restait
on investissant dans le renouvellement
de son réseau et en recrutant des agents
la ville a découvert avec surprise
qu'elle faisait encore de belles
économies
il y a une baisse du tarif concernant en
fait le ce qu'on appelle nous les frais
fixes en gros c'est l'abonnement ça
correspond ça correspondait à 30% du
prix de l'abonnement ça veut dire que du
coup les recettes de la régie c'était
enfin je crois on était amis en 370000
euros mais on est arrivé à mettre
régulièrement 400 000 euros de côté et
alors cet argent il a pas été dépensé
pour des actionnaires il a pas été
dépensé j'allais dire pour des pour
financer j'allais dire des équipes trop
nombreuses parce que c'est un peu ça des
fois qui pratiquait cette émie de côté
en fait pour avoir un système qui
permettait de diminuer le calcaire de
l'eau
dans l'eau dans l'eau des abrévisiens
voilà
inauguré en 2021 l'usine de traitement
du calcaire et le choix des habitants de
Saint-Jean-de-Braye qui ont préféré
investir dans cette technique innovante
plutôt que d'alléger encore plus leurs
factures
[Musique]
alors là effectivement on a des flacons
des moins qui montrent le résultat hier
si vous preniez de l'eau sorti de
déférisation des manganisations vous la
faites bouillir et ben voici le taux de
calcaire que vous aviez dans votre
casserole aujourd'hui maintenant que
l'usine est en fonctionnement ben voici
le taux de calcaire que vous avez cette
fois ci dans votre casserole donc le
résultat il est parlant on parle de
d'allongement de durée de vie pour la
machine à laver et pour l'ensemble des
équipements électroménagers vous voyez
là ils sont en train ils ont résiné un
certain endroit où on avait des
concrétions derrière sur le bâtiment et
qui est dépassé financé grâce aux
économies faites à Saint-Jean-de-Braye
l'usine est aujourd'hui gérée par la
métropole d'Orléans qui a récupéré la
compétence de la gestion de l'eau
les 22 communes de son périmètre n'ont
pas réussi à se mettre d'accord pour
choisir soit une régie publique soit un
délégataire privé commun à Orléans le
système privé a encore ses partisans
la résine est pas forcément la solution
idéale de ce que j'ai vu sur la
métropole et du mixte que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est une espèce d'émulation
une capacité en recherche et
développement et en technicité des
délégataires que nous n'avons pas
forcément sur les régimes je ne pense
pas que une régie totale sur la
métropole aurait été moins cher pas en
tout cas dans le contexte que nous avons
de besoin d'investissement de de besoin
technique pour des eaux qui sont pas
très très propres
tous ces arguments fait que on n'était
pas en mesure d'offrir le même service
d'offrir le même renouvellement à un
prix
plus bas que ce que nous allons proposer
le choix du service public que n'a pas
fait Orléans Paris Bordeaux et Lyon
l'ont fait
en 15 ans le pourcentage d'habitants
desservis par une régie a augmenté de 38
à 48%. une évolution qui s'expliquerait
par les avantages économiques
écologiques de la régie selon les
travaux d'une mission d'enquête
parlementaire transpartisane
qu'est-ce qu'on a observé lorsque on
regarde le privé qui gère de l'eau dans
les communes d'abord 25% de surcoût par
rapport à une gestion publique de l'eau
donc les usagers payent plus cher sur
leur facture le fait que ça soit les
privés on l'explique très facilement
c'est parce que lorsque vous avez une
régie publique de l'eau vous n'avez pas
besoin ni d'avoir bon d'actionnaires de
payer des actionnaires si c'est le cas
de Veolia de Suez et d'autres vous
n'avez pas besoin de payer de
commerciaux pour aller convaincre des
mairies de signer avec vous on a
beaucoup plus de rendement efficace avec
une régie publique que avec une gestion
déléguée au privé pourquoi parce que
vous payez un volume lorsque vous payez
au privé et donc forcément si vous ne
rénovez pas un rythme suffisant vos
réseaux dos et bien le volume qui sort
et qui est gaspillé par par ses réseaux
et en quelque sorte facturé aux usagers
donc payer au délégataires privés donc
il a moins intérêt à faire attention à
ces réseaux d'eau que une régie publique
qui elle va être plus économe sur ces
questions
[Musique]
être capable de financer le
renouvellement du réseau pour limiter
les fuites ce sera l'un des défis de ses
prochaines années pour les opérateurs
publics et privés actuellement 20% du
volume prélevé se perd avant d'arriver
jusqu'à nos robinets soit plus de 1300
milliards de litres payés et gaspiller